-
MPAK TORY.T
>>SUHE
OCEAAR THESORETHTHE WEE
UP CLOSEANO
LOSA
PLACE IN CUB PERHAPS WOULD
ONLY A SMALL HD IVVOTEON SHAIR ,
HE SHO
BULLDOGS CF
E SEE LYS. AROUND ME FOR A CLOR
[INTERPRETER]
FECT PERFECT PRETOPI
OG A RK
NE
01A PLACED
RERI ON SHARRUSSIAN.
AR IES IN T CARIBBEAN T
HE ACCIDENTALLY
ECENVIROA WA TIS>>EO CARIBBEAN U
NLCA
EITHER FORAUTHEYERE CONSERNUISA.
'S NOT JUSVAONTOIS
OMING E A SHARKS,
ONS OFRSNU
EFORE HER FOR STIVERS
SHARKS, CANAAN TOURISTS,
>> I WATCH THE VIFD
IN POOLS, ONOCCHWI
UIARFISH TO AT
SHEYAREFUL T
E NICEARAYY'VE N
PEOPLE WHO TOYACT>> IT'E MYTH K
INER,
ESSIVE, HE S MAND HAFROM M AND Y
STE OF MTHAR WH
INCREDLYIFUL.
ADRENA ARM, THEYADE
CA.YO MAI BRESSIVE
TURES.